[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday the 6th of
July I'm Kate Andrews the spectator's
economics editor and your host this week
coming up on the show
riots in France with hundreds of people
arrested and cities on fire are other
European leaders asking could this
happen here I'll speak to the spectators
chairman Andrew Neil and Jonathan Miller
who wrote Our cutter piece this week
this week marks 75 years of the NHS is
there much to celebrate I'll be speaking
to former Health secretary Sacha Javid
about the state of the Health Service
and what its future might look like
Rishi cnx ratings have fallen into the
negative for the first time since he
entered number 10. as the fifth
by-election looms following Chris
Pinter's suspension how are things
faring for the Tories I'll speak to our
political editor Katie balls
over in America there are rumors
circulating that the bidens are backing
Ursula Vander lion to be the next NATO
leader Freddie gray joins me on the show
to discuss corruption and friends in
politics
and finally this comes with a trigger
warning following the decision made by a
Publishing House in the United States to
put a trigger warning on Virginia
Woolf's work who might be flagged next
I'll be speaking to Tom Slater from
spite
and if you enjoy spectator TV then do
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon to
make sure you never miss an episode
first up for our cover piece this week
Jonathan Miller has written about the
rides taking place across cities in
France a problem that has intensified
across Europe recently he joins me now
alongside our chairman Andrew Neal
Jonathan you write in this week's cover
piece for the magazine that Europe is
approaching a boiling point as gang
violence is rising up across several
countries I want to start by asking you
about the recent riots in France what's
it been like living there well in all
Villages it's been absolutely
unremarkable except that the
conversation in the cafe is one of
enormous uh annoyance that this should
be happening yet again France is in a
almost Perpetual state of
ayating and attacks but this was
unusually severe and it was provoked by
the death of the 17 year old boy in the
suburb of Paris who was shot by the
police refusing to stop for a control
and a bit like George Floyd in America a
person who did not have an unimpeachable
character nahel also was involved with
gangs he had 14 previous encounters with
the police but his killing was enough to
provoke an insurgence really across from
in these bolier terrible suburbs that
surround every French city and it went
on for several days hundreds of police
have been injured a number of people
have been killed the government
initially appeared paralyzed but with
the uh the police action
um seems for the moment to have subsided
but although it's subsided that low
level intensity of of gang violence in
France continues and the fundamental
problems are not solved no politician
seems to have a clue what to do about it
and sadly
the prospect is that it could become
worse Jonathan you write in your piece
that like many riots across many
countries there will be some people who
are actively pursuing a sense of social
justice but there will be other groups
who are trying to capitalize on the
moment and cause chaos what's the
balance like at the moment in France I
would say that most of the really
violent action was committed by
opportunists and gangs uh you know
because looting sharp or burning down a
supermarket or a Renault dealer is not
really a form of protest that sort of
violent Behavior Uh is more classified
as a sort of insurrection or a criminal
opportunism there are those who've
protested the situation but even there
there's some some questions I just
exactly what the circumstances were and
it will remain for the criminal justice
system to determine exactly what
happened Andrew what to make of macron's
response to these riots well he survived
them
which were much more extensive
demonstrations and pretty violent in
Paris and other big cities for a while
he survived the anti-pension reform
demonstrations as well he saw that
they're more often he's seen this off
it's all beginning to Peter out there
was a lot of um
sort of excited coverage particularly in
the Anglo-Saxon media including may I
say The Spectator online that France was
on the brink of Civil War and riots that
would bring down the government and the
Army would have to be deployed it was
all stuff and nonsense and these things
happen there isn't a country in Europe
that isn't a one police shooting away
from serious rights I mean this could
happen in every major city in Europe
even this country where our race
relations are pretty much better than
anywhere else it could even happen in a
place like Malvo and Sweden could happen
in Germany it happened in Belgium it's
it's spilled over could certainly happen
in Italy it was never going to be a
threat to the government itself it was
the The Rise was serious there were a
lot of violence there's a an
underclasses being created many of us
shortcoming years and years ago but
nothing was done about it and this
underclass in the bonjour in the ghettos
in the a suburb exists in a mixture of
welfare dependency and uh quite violent
criminality and how you deal with that
because we've dealt with it basically
but just shutting it off uh the the
there but although it's these serious
social problem it is not a threat to the
state
embarrassment to the state it's an
expensive danger to the state because
all these businesses have to be rebuilt
but when revolutions are not built on
rise in which the average age of the
people arrested is 17. the reason why
laser venomor in 1968 were far more
significant was it wasn't just the
students who were writing in major
cities and and going for a revolution
the unions joined in the working class
joined in as well that was a threat to
the state now the goal saw it off and
then this was not a threat to the eighth
state it was a symptom
an Insurgency of a deep-rooted social
problem that has taken place that has
allowed an underclass to take roots of a
particular ethnic and migrant background
in the most generous welfare state in
the world so if it can happen in France
it can happen anywhere and I am ADD and
I agree with you that it's not a threat
to the state itself but it is left
Emmanuel macron seriously diminished uh
we recall that when macron was first
elected he was on the cover of The
Economist magazine walking on water and
after the passage of Merkel or he his
ambition was to become the leader of
Europe that I just around you that's
also the magazine that had Angela Merkel
as the leader of the World perhaps not a
magazine we should take too much notice
of Perhaps Perhaps what's the code again
I I forget but they can't I think we
both used to work there actually we did
that was when dinosaurs walk to the
earth I mean France obviously since 1789
it's had this revolutionary tradition
and this these latest events were not
the most violent there is an interesting
parallel that apparently during these
recent writes animals were freed from
the zoo which also happened in 1789 the
difference was that in 1789 they ate the
animals and so but nevertheless macron
couldn't go to the European Summit on
migration and now the political Center
in France is menaced by the rise of
Maureen Le Pen who is looks like the
favorite to win the next election but I
have to fear that she will only make
matters worse because she has no real
ideas for how to deal with this and in
fact across Europe nobody seems to have
a particularly good idea of how to
definitively resolve this problem of
these uh areas infested with gangs
infested with crime with young people
completely disconnected from education
and opportunity unemployable except
perhaps in criminality well let's Branch
out from France Jonathan because in your
cover piece you look at disruptions
happening in other countries like
Germany and Sweden well particularly
Sweden which is but you know now the
country in Europe with the highest
proportion of migrants in Europe 25
percent uh quintessential example of a
liberally minded social democracy
um and which opened its arms to receive
these people and is now uh the police in
Sweden I think believe there are was it
38 000 uh gangsters they're mostly young
they're incredibly violent uh the
current Swedish criminal justice system
is really quite incapable of dealing
with them I took in my piece about a
Hitman who killed the wrong person was
sentenced to four years in prison it's
promptly escaped but was granted Swedish
citizenship simultaneously and now in
teachers teachers in Sweden are being
told by their students it's you're worth
four years I can do I can kill you and
I'll only get four years for it so that
shows the the degeneration of Swedish
Society into something that is
really threatening to this reputation
Andrew and Jonathan's piece he also
talks about migration and the potential
connection between what's been happening
there and the riots I wonder sometimes
especially when we're looking at Asylum
Seekers and how they're coming into the
country is the issue the systems
themselves or a lack of a system in the
UK for example there basically is no
functioning Asylum system there are very
few legal Pathways for Asylum Seekers to
come here only from a few select
countries and you end up in a position
where you don't know who a lot of the
people coming into the country are is
the issue of failure of a system or just
a complete lack of a system in place
well I don't think it's a silence
because they're writing it's uh you can
only it's migrants or actually in the
case of Francis people who are kids who
were born are friends you know they're
French but they don't feel part of
French society and it's quite hard to
know exactly what could be done about
this after all one of the features I
mean the ghetto is an American
expression and one of the features of
the ghetto historically is in the 60s or
70s was mass unemployment well actually
there's a huge labor shortage in in
France at the moment people are crying
out for labor that's true in Britain
it's true in Germany as well it's even
becoming true in in Italy certainly true
in Sweden who've been talking about so
it can't be that you have a a kind of
unemployed youth there I think a lot of
these youngsters have found it
culturally more attractive to be
involved in low-level crime uh than to
have a proper job much to the despair of
their parents who are first generation
migrants and wanted to make it in France
or in the countries that they've gone to
so I don't think it's the Asylum system
I think it it is a problem of
assimilating migrants it's turned out
now the Europeans were always terribly
Superior when they looked at the United
States and America's race problems and
all the discrimination and the
difficulties and and so on and the riots
that they had in the 60s in watts and
Harlem and so on well they don't look so
Superior now because actually Europe
excluding Britain Europe has proved to
be much less capable of assimilating and
absorbing large numbers of migrants than
America which is built on migration or
even Britain and one of the problems
that France faces Germany as it to some
extent too is that the migrant
population there first second third
generation particularly in France are
all almost one of a kind they are nearly
all of North African extraction or
origin or culture
and they're nearly all Muslim whereas if
you look at the British migration
picture it's incredibly varied you know
Christians from Africa Hindus from India
including our own dear prime minister uh
is is from from their Muslims yes sir as
as well uh West Indians uh Africans
sub-Saharan North African
subcontinent Middle East Afghanistan now
Ukraine much more varied which therefore
means within Britain you get
differential performance among Mike and
gripsole Chinese migrants perform better
than anybody way better than the
indigenous white population those of
Indian extraction perform really well
too those of Pakistani extraction less
well but you don't get a kind of uniform
picture whereas in France and to some
extent in Germany too because all the
migrants have roughly the same
background not all of them but a lot of
them you get the same problem repeated
again and again whereas you go to
Leicester and Britain you will see a
thriving migrant City
go to Rochdale
you see a not so thriving migrant City
I'd have to say coming back to England
for one of my brief visits
one is slightly encouraged by the
different uh
situation in Britain compared to France
I think in France there is really a an
almost institutional racism these kids
have very little access to higher
education the women are invisible
whereas I come to London and I see The
Splendid example of how people can rub
against each other and live happily
which is not say that Britain is
necessarily immune they may just take
one please we had you know the rights in
2011 we've had you know there are local
difficulties
um the idea of an of a national eruption
is somewhat improbable yeah in in
Britain compared to France well that's
the last question I want to put to you
Angie you mentioned this at the start of
our conversation uh that you think that
these kinds of disruptions these kinds
of riots could be set off in other
countries do you think other European
leaders are looking at the situation in
France and to some extent Sweden and
Germany and thinking we could be next
well I think there's no question about
that I think every leader in Europe and
clearly I I would suggest our own dear
prime minister should be thinking this
too that we're all only one police
bullet away from a riot uh particularly
if that police bullet is fired in
suspicious circumstances such
circumstances that become hard to defend
whatever we'll find out in the end more
visible on social media yes and social
media has made it much worse personally
has made it much worse and this was
demonstrated with George Floyd in
America with DC were propagated and of
course one of the things that macron has
done is imposed really quite quite tough
censorship on social media for the
diffusion of these videos
which can certainly backfire if people
think well I think this was the action
of a totalitarian state and I'm no fan
of macron but he has a point that that
Twitter and Instagram create a kind of
mass mass sort of psychosis in which
people see people doing terrible things
and in imitate it
the final point though that I'd like to
throw into this is just as in France
we're seeing the rise and Rise of Marine
Le Pen and her renamed the national from
the Russian Belmont National there is I
think this is going to track Europe more
broadly to the right and we're seeing in
Spain as a general election coming
coming up in which the traditional
socialists are being outpaced by a
right-wing party and we see this uh we
see this in Italy where Maloney as prime
minister she's often described as
extreme right she's not extrema but they
are right the problem is that in common
with all these right-wing politicians is
none of them really have a clue not to
do have they like all politicians they
think that saying something is the
equivalent of doing something so you're
hearing a lot of words we have to cure
this problem we have to address the
issues what exactly are the policies I
mean the Europe has had a lost decade
yeah
you know after the Euro crisis of
unemployment rates were you know scary
among youngsters I mean they're
unemployment rate in Italy among young
teenagers reach 40 percent at one stage
it was a disaster and I think there's a
danger is that Europe now faces a second
lost decade too particularly if the ECB
keeps on raising interest rates and
tackling money there'll be another
decade of no growth that makes it very
hard to solve problems I don't say
growth growth on its own solves the
problems but it does make it easier to
deal with the problems there's more
money in the treasury to deal with them
that doesn't help I think the other
thing related to France that I find most
scary is that these these riots as they
have in America and the the cultural
significance of America is unbelievable
I don't believe this would be happening
in France over the past weekend if it
hadn't been for George Floyd in the
first place that set the example of what
you do when when people in the poorest
part see what they think a racial
Injustice on the part of the police you
Riot you set fire and you need this time
unlike 2005 in France they went into the
city centers in 2005 they largely stayed
rather stupidly burning their own
regions but areas this time they were
the expensive ones and I think the
danger
as this encourages extremes so melanchol
on the left has been in there stirring
things up he's a kind of pujitis
populist of the left and of course as
Jonathan says Madame Le Pen has a new
lease of Life the real danger in France
is that the mainstream right and the
mainstream left are dead in the water
macrame killed them they barely exist
but macron can run again as president
and I suspect his party falls apart when
he goes that it has no future Beyond
macron so what's the political response
the center cannot hold to quote an Irish
shirt poet and the extremes are rampant
and the riots make that worse I think
that's the political danger of what
happened in France over the past week
Andrew and Jonathan thanks for joining
me
next the Prime Minister opposition
leader and even some members of the
royal family gathered in Westminster
Abbey this week to sing the Praises of
the NHS now 75 years old isn't it about
time we had some of those difficult
conversations about what's going wrong
in the Health Service joining me now is
former Health secretary Sacha Javid
Sacha thank you for joining spectator TV
thank you to start we've had 13 years of
Tory rule how is the NHS doing now
well the NHS is getting record amounts
of funding it's dealing with more people
and more patients than ever before this
history it's got more doctors and nurses
than ever before it's had to deal with a
a pandemic which we haven't seen the
likes of for decades and so in many
senses it's it's doing well in terms of
looking after so many people but when
you compare the NHS to other Universal
Health Care Systems in countries we
often compare ourselves to our neighbors
in Europe or Australia Japan and other
places the health outcomes which
ultimately I think is what matters in
most uh to people are definitely not as
good as they should be you've become
very vocal recently about calling for
Change and calling for reform of the NHS
what has propelled you to do that
well after having been Health secretary
and as well as having obviously other
jobs in government which I was dealing
with the the Department of Health and
Social care it's uh
it's it's become more of a challenge I
think because of the pandemic but even
before the pandemic you know I think we
could see because of an aging Society
because of the the changes in the burden
of disease especially since the NHS was
created because of the expectations that
people rightly have for the latest drugs
and recruitments so we've seen the surge
in demand and uh Supply hasn't been
keeping up and I I think you know when
we all sort of look at it and we do an
honest assessment the fact that so many
people are waiting for GPS they're
waiting for a e they're waiting for
ambulances they're waiting for scans and
operations you know that's not it's far
from ideal and I think we have to then
look at that and and think to ourselves
you know when funding is at such a
record high then what are the causes of
this how come other countries aren't
facing necessarily the same issues in
delivery when they all have the same
challenges of rising demand and I think
we have to you as politicians you'll be
honest in our assessment and and instead
of what I think sometimes is a sort of
politicians also leaning into you know
adulation competing with each other is
to say look you know where the NHS works
well great but if it doesn't work well
if it's not delivering what British
people would rightly expect we should be
honest and and have an assessment and
have a serious debate about its future
and what's the best way to make it fit
for the future I remember when you
became Health secretary you made a point
of not wearing that NHS badge that many
Health secretaries before it did and I I
seem to recall that the suggestion was
you know I I don't want to be glorifying
the system I I want to see what works
and what doesn't for doctors and nurses
and patients and the rest but you are by
no means as vocal as you are now about
the necessary reform that you think
needs to take place what is going so
wrong in the political discussion that
it takes an MP who was who was leading
the Health Service but has now announced
that they're going to be stepping down
and not running for reelection that only
at that point did politicians to feel
comfortable to start talking about this
stuff
well I think for yeah and you're right
it is about politicians it's not one
particular party I think all the major
political parties uh have been the you
really when it comes to the NHS just
sort of focusing on focusing on on
almost treating it like a religion like
the rest of the country as though you
know it's above criticism and at the end
of the day we must remember it's a it's
a Health Service uh and it's they're
really obviously for all of us but what
we want out to it are the best outcomes
and I think where politicians get stuck
really is that they are very afraid uh
to speak honestly and openly about the
challenges the NHS and how to fix them
because frankly they just don't want to
get their head shot off they just feel
that they think that's not what the
public want to hear but interestingly
you know I I've started you know talking
about the NHS a lot recently as you say
about the the future of it as I am
deeply concerned about it
um just the the last couple of days I
wrote about it in in in the times and
elsewhere and I can tell you just today
I had I've had so many emails from
people from the public you're coming in
to be unsolicited about my comments the
vast majority in support of what I'm
saying which is let's have an honest
debate let's have a royal commission but
interestingly when I was looking at them
uh earlier today the the so vast
majority of support but most of those
that are in support from people working
inside the NHS doctors nurses for
selfish and inside the NHS uh talking
about this and and saying yeah it's
great that you know you Sergeant you
know Tony Blair today and others are
openly talking about the kind of things
that need change yeah another politician
talking about change is Shadow Health
secretary Wes streeting does it worry
you as a Tory MP that labor might be
bolder on this topic and might be
offering up more solutions come the next
general election than your own party no
not really look I I want to see a NHS
that's fit for the future and I think to
get there we are going to need new
politicians on all sides to to work
together you know one of one of the
things that we've had in this country
for many many years is a sort of
settlement let's say on the NH it's a
political settlement and and by and
large for many years that's that serve
the country well up until you know more
recently where these challenges that we
now face uh that sort of settlement
almost is stopping an honest debate but
going forward if we don't want the NHS
to be used as a day-to-day political
football I think getting all politicians
to agree that there are you know some
serious problems that it does require
and honest assessment and and there are
you in a Green Way Forward now I think
the way forward is a royal commission
um I I read the other day west region is
saying it's not the whole commission but
I I think that you know actually getting
all poor teachers to agree to a way
forward to an honest assessment with uh
with experts as well as politicians
involved and then when this war
commission recruits back having uh the
government of the day make the decisions
you know as it should in a proper
Democratic fashion is the Right Way
Forward I want to ask you a little bit
about money because again you were house
secretary you will have had detailed
understanding about how much money is
really funneled into the Health Service
I think it's now approaching about 44 of
Public Service day-to-day spending
um I think there's this almost Universal
assumption that one of the struggles for
the NHS is that it was so badly
underfunded by Tory governments during
the years of austerity but if you look
back and you look at government only
spending the NHS consistently ranks in
the top four countries trees in the
oecd's rankings for government only
spending do you think that money is the
problem do you think the system is the
problem one thing I'm curious about is
whether or not the system is actually
stopping more money from going in
because if we look at these other
Universal systems they're much more
pragmatic about combining State and
private sector money to top up their
Health Service yeah the the NHS as we
know relies almost entirely on taxpayer
funding unlike as you've rightly pointed
out many of the watch all other
Universal Health Care Systems so when we
talk about countries like Germany and
France and Italy and Japan and no longer
Australia right all of them right now
but they all all those countries by the
way by having a Universal Health Care
System unlike let's say United States
which is a system I would not want to
see anything like that here in the UK If
you compare ourselves to other just
other European countries is the as you
say they have funding from multiple
sources now the Lion's Share is probably
still come coming from the state one way
or the other but people are able to
contribute in almost all those countries
they contribute in a means-tested way so
the end result of that is that as a
value I think we can all sign up to
which is that uh anyone in a country no
matter who they are should get you know
world-class Health Care uh but based on
their needs you know based on their you
know on their means and their ability
right so your means should not hold you
back from getting uh the care uh that
you need and so that's how these
countries have approached it what
happens in the UK and I haven't seen
this just from the perspective of the
health secretary but as Chancellor as
well is that when at any chance that
when they're allocating uh funding of
course there's many other trade-offs uh
to be made you know you need to what
about education what about especially
now defense costs are going up interest
rate zero going up you know all of those
need Government funding as well so
inevitably there's trade-offs and a
Chancellor will look at the biggest
budget in you know in in government the
NHS and in every the NHS will have to be
a consequence of that trade-off so it
the the to avoid that to some extent you
I think having a look at other models of
care and how they're funded is is the
right thing uh to do uh but also uh is
to you I mean look at the overall
funding is to realize that it's not a
question of funding in the other
countries with less funding seem to be
getting better outcomes so you have to
look at the model and you have to look
at many other aspects of healthcare I I
think it's very interesting that you've
had so many people writing to you since
your comments and the times saying that
they broadly speaking agree with you
how do you process getting these
messages from patients who are having a
tough time with the sites that we saw
this week at Westminster Abbey with
politicians praying over the NHS doing
readings essentially giving sermons I
mean in my mind it really doesn't add up
whether I I think there is when you look
at the NHS especially over the 75-year
history I think when we're especially if
we're talking about the people that work
in the NHS the doctors that nurses
consultants and yeah anyone who's
working the nhsa any capacity I think
these people are are in my experience
they are people that work incredibly
hard they're incredibly dedicated
they're compassion caring people but
they are working within the structures
that have been created for them
ultimately by politicians of of many
parties successive governments and that
broad structure of the NHS hasn't
changed when the world around it has
changed dramatically and so the the the
the people in the NHS you know I think
they do deserve thanks for doing what
they do but I think if we are to
properly support them we must realize
the the the the the the challenges that
they work in can be you know alleviated
to a huge extent if we as politicians
take a dispassionate look uh the NHS and
destruction last question uh you became
Health secretary well into 2021 as we
were looking to lift restrictions and go
back to normal life I know you weren't
there at the height of lockdown yeah and
a lot of what we're seeing now
especially with these record waiting
lists as a result of people staying at
home and treatments vastly delayed do
you think in retrospect that
stay-at-home messaging to protect the
NHS was a mistake
um I don't know in terms of um the the
the the the nature of your question
because I don't think we have enough
data yet in the the NHS has compared to
other countries has less capacity when
you look at it in terms of beds versus
say you know Germany has something like
seven uh your beds per thousand when we
have two or three when you look at it in
terms of your scanning equipment and
your number of doctors and nurses it has
less capacity than most other European
countries and intentionally run that way
to stay and it's been run that yes the
NHS is is running about 95 capacity when
in most of the countries in Europe they
went around 80 85 capacity so when it
was already running at a very high sort
of rate before the pandemic hit I I
think you know obviously I wasn't there
at the time but I could understand
reasons as to why the decisions that
were made were made uh I I think I don't
want to even though I've been there as
health secretary you're doing Puff the
pandemic let's say I don't want to
really second guess the decisions that
were made at the time because I don't
feel I have all the information
Sacha thanks for joining spectator TV
good thank you very much
next up another tough week for Rishi
CNAC as his ratings fell into the
negative for the first time since he
became prime minister joining me now is
our political editor Katie Bowles Katie
thanks for joining spectator TV so the
parliament stanzer's Watchdog has
recommended that Chris pincher be
suspended as an MP for eight weeks
falling investigations of sexual
misconduct now this Scandal brings us
back to the Boris Johnson era really it
was the revelation of the Scandal that
started some of those resignations that
ultimately led to Boris Johnson leaving
can you remind us of the situation and
also tell us what happens next Chris
pincher ultimately was accused of
groping an individual at a late night
event and it was then number 10
subsequent mishandling in the view of
MPS that triggered as you say those mass
resignations and this report looks into
the alleged incident and as a result of
what they say is Chris pinch's behavior
and he is now facing an a-week
suspension and that means there's not
definitely a by-election because it has
to be a recall petition
um and then you have to have 10 of the
constituency sign it and if you think
about the way these things go it's very
likely that this will now be a
by-election and that means where she's
seen it already has three by-elections
on the 10th of July we had the threat of
the Nadine Doris by-election still
hanging over at the party and much to
the annoyance I think of her former
colleagues that she won't just go and
but that's the mid bedfordshire by
election when we get it and it means
that there will also be Chris pincher
and a by-election and Tamworth history
it's a fairly safe seat it's a majority
around nineteen thousand but
I think it's a it's a problem for which
you see like in two ways by-elections
tend to be worse for the gambling
parties and so a state you might have a
chance winning in it or holding in a
general election you're more likely to
lose in a by-election you're much more
like to get tactical voting anti-tory
vote but you can also get in a general
election but particularly in
by-elections and then also
you have to question uh whether number
10 cchq and the whips office have really
uh handled or prepared for this
correctly because only a few weeks ago
Eddie Hughes is an MP who won a red wool
seat
um in 2017 his seat goes in the boundary
Commission in review and he's been
adopted as a candidate for Tamworth now
that's quite that is ultimately the tour
is down a bind which is where he to
stand now as the by-election candidate
in that seat he would have to quit his
currency sparking a by-election and will
also wear his seat is
um which has a much smaller majority
um in terms of what we can expect to
happen there and so there would still
have to be a by-election or I think
what's probably more likely is he stays
put but then what happens in the sense
of looking for a Tory candidate to stand
in a by-election which is normally a
pretty horrible experience and and if
and if they do hold it uh when the
boundaries change do they then stand or
does any cues come in so you're
potentially looking for someone to stand
in the seat just for the sake of it and
I think um there's a few MPS asking why
they didn't think about this before
selecting an MP a few weeks ago it does
seem like a rather bureaucratic
oversight and one that the Tory party
would want to be on top of given the
fact that this is a difficult position
for them to start in why not try to make
the best of it if you're already in a
difficult position yes exactly and like
maybe there's a solution that all the
MPS I've spoken to who at first presumed
there was a solution but now I think
there is one is there is and you know
we're missing it but I think it's just
adding to a sense of yes more
by-election misery but also a lack of
control and Griff about what's coming up
even when some of these things are quite
predictable and we knew there would be
the report into Chris pincher and and I
think for Rishi like you just go back to
the fact that the recovery Narrative of
perhaps the spring feels quite a long
way ago you have the naval lead
increasing or you know the gap between
the to widening I think every
by-election just means that even if
Richard Cena got some good weather good
political weather
um these votes have the potential to
really bring him back to just in the way
that local elections did well I was
wondering about that the actual number
of by-elections
um as that number Rises does the
situation get worse for the Tories do
you think or does the number not matter
so much whether it's three whether it's
five whether it's seven you know the
narrative is already established these
are going to be tough by elections the
Tories might not do so well does it go
in from three to five make a big
difference I just think it means it's
ongoing
um ultimately the Tories and figures and
number 10 but of like Nadine Doris to
actually do what she said she was going
to do on Twitter late on a you know
actually fairly early on a Friday it was
Boris Johnson he was later
um and and officially resigns they could
get all the by-elections out of the way
so if number 10 had their way you'd have
four by-elections on the 20th of July
instead they can only have three it was
already a frustration to have one
hanging over you had friends friends of
Nadine Doris briefing out that she
wouldn't let rashish you know choose the
date she wanted almost to prolong his
misery and I think that is obviously
evidence of how having these events
there's just almost ways to trip up as
you as you try and move the agenda on so
I think it's damaging in that
perspective because yes at XX number of
defeats it's going to look worse than a
smaller number but also it's just when
is this going to be does Richardson go
into the Autumn when they're going to
try and I don't want to say reset but
definitely try and take control of
things through The King's Speech through
the conference speech potentially for a
reshuffle whether it's list side of the
summer recess or the other side
um and I think having by-elections will
just uh you know always spook your party
and that's unhelpful to him it's more
bad news for the Prime Minister who this
week saw his uh ratings his approval
ratings fall into the negative for the
first time since he became prime
minister yes this was amongst Tory
supporters so it was a Quantum home
cabinet League table and they'd do those
monthly and Richard is in the negative
for the first one since entering number
ten he's only slightly there so Paul
Goodman the editor of consent poems that
the only country he could offer where
she see nag is Theresa May and Boris
Johnson at various points so we're in
the negative but fed much much lower I
think it was quite worrying to the
government is there they never told them
nine ministers in the negative which is
the first time it's happened in that
table and that just suggests I think a
general unhappiness
not perhaps a fury born as a despondency
which you see amongst some of the MPS at
the moment as well and therefore what
does Rishi C90 to try and get some
momentum back I think it's also quite
interesting in terms of a reshuffled
because lots of the most loyal where
she's seen it backers are actually in
the negative and then at the top of the
table you have Ben Wallace who there's
questions about because the seat is
being abolished whether he stays in the
cabinet and Kami badenark uh you have
Steve Barkley's tip to move and and
therefore If he if he does what some are
expecting him to do around him and you
potentially uh get rid of something more
popular ministers and you know every
politician is different in the way that
they view who they want to be their top
people around them will Rishi Cena
prioritize loyalty in what he considers
to be hard work over the polls will he
try to balance this or at this point
will his number 10 be looking at these
figures and think gosh we need to be
more popular we're going to have to
embrace people towards the top even if
they wouldn't normally be our first pick
so I think we give ministers who are
popularizatory Grassroots so this is
going to be what those in number 10
expect to be the final shake-up of his
front bench team ahead of an election
and if you think back to 2014 David
Cameron did a very tactical one and
moved out his more unpopular ministers
even if they were good at reform such as
Michael go he got moved to Chief whip
Nikki Morgan was seen as more appealing
in the media and less divisive with the
teachers and became education secretary
so it depends what you're trying to
achieve I think Rishi Cena wants to
still do things in government he doesn't
have enough to point to so it can't all
be about media but they want ministers
he'll go out on the media and defend the
government recently there wasn't a
government representation when there was
a question time brexit special yeah so
if the government can't defend what was
doing on brexit why should anyone else
yeah and so I think they want to fix
that by having more enthusiastic figures
going out there and and he also wants
loyalty and perhaps not worrying so much
about balancing the warring factions and
delivery so who's back in those priority
areas to try and push those things but I
think the reason this poll actually is
quite important is if you think about
the election next year they are going to
need to get activists out they're going
to need a good Grand game and that's
very hard to do when you have an
unmotivated base and therefore I think
you have to be a little bit careful
about doing anything that's going to
turn away the membership and make them
less inclined to actually get out and
what's clearly and be a very difficult
election campaign looking at a different
party and a potential government in
Waiting certainly they think a labor
party's leader accused armor gave a
speech this morning on his five missions
not five pledges and Promises like where
she seen our commissions but the
emphasis was on education what is the
labor party telling the public so this
is about opportunity is how they're
branding it as a mission but as you say
it's education policy is the main focus
and I think that's probably one of the
most interesting things that they've
been talking about is oracy which is
effectively making
um lessons when you're teaching children
in school making how you speak and
making sure you can talk and explain
your ideas and always public speaking
but just building up that confidence as
something that would be a key part and
making that compulsory and pitching that
in the sense of they think that would do
a lot when it comes to
well you're starting to seeing the
difference of some leaving private
school very confident public speakers
and some of you even are very nervous
about that and so I think that's
probably the announcement that's got the
most traction so far and but we also
know some of the labels other policies
in school so abolishing uh you know vat
relief when it comes to private schools
and those plans are staying put um so I
think all in all they're trying to pitch
themselves as much more uh
on the side of State schools I think
that's fair to say but using that as a
way to say you know opportunity for all
and the question of course is what uh
consequences has in terms of some of
these economic measures in terms of the
future of private schools yeah labor
argue it will make no difference but um
obviously the independent school bodies
say quite differently uh indeed and I
think there are questions about whether
or not the money that they think they'll
raise from abolishing their boot relief
will actually be raised and also that
money is doing a lot of work you often
hear when you know the non-dom money and
the private school money in terms of how
it is apparently being spent it's pretty
wide for quite small pots of money yes
it's almost like it's the new
corporation tax hike of the Jeremy
corbyn years um but I mean this this is
a serious point for the labor party
they've had to scale back some of those
pledges they were making around green
investment uh Rachel Reeves made the
announcement she was going to be scaling
back that 28 billion that labor would
eventually deliver on it but but not
right away that might have gotten more
attraction if Big Bore Shelton news
hadn't come out a few hours later but
they are have they clearly want to spend
more money but they know that they need
the Optics at least need to make this
seem like it's costed
yes
um and I think Rachel Reeves exactly as
you say is prioritizing that above other
things hence the 28 billion borrowing
for green jobs has been scaled down
they're interestingly at this launch of
kissed armor you had protesters and who
actually turned on him for watering it
down suggesting he was abandoning uh
climate change uh was you know so you
can see the tension actually between
within the left on it I think
is I was wondering is that protest
damaging to Kirsten I think Summoners
team might actually not mind it at all
yeah and because it shows he's they like
either he's standing up to some forces
in his powers to try to push him in
various directions and I think it comes
down to a little bit
is it the case that someone in the labor
party and then the general left movement
feel so isolated by kirst armor that
they then vote green and they're betting
that won't happen and and I think the
plan is to try and have a few more
almost get some of the stuff out of the
way and Advance the election so you have
some more policies that appeal to them
closer to it okay thanks for joining me
next following rumors that Joe Biden has
recommended the president of the
European commission Ursula Vander Lyon
to be the next head of NATO our Deputy
editor Freddie gray is with me to talk
about their relationship and what kind
of career she's had
Freddie thanks for joining spectator TV
great pleasure Kate so it seems Joe
Biden has some strong opinions about who
he would like to be the next leader of
NATO and it is none other than Ursula
Vander Lyon what do you make of that
Fred well we heard some whispers about
this a couple of months ago a Brilliance
to bike picked up on some rumors that
Jill Biden has been telling Joe that the
next Secretary General of NATO has to be
a woman and of course this sounded too
ought to be true but often with stories
that are too ought to be true they
actually turn out to have a bit of a
grain of Truth in them and it seems as
though Gilbert and Joe Biden have
definitely got involved in who's going
to be the next Secretary General of NATO
Ben Wallace thought he had it there may
be very good reasons for not giving Ben
Wallace the job
however it seems like the reason is Jill
and Joe were against and America as you
know Kate as an American has an enormous
amount of power
uh and they did not like the idea of Ben
Wallace they had other ideas in mind and
it seems now that they like Ursula
Wonderland as their candidate we'll get
into Biden's opinions and America's
thoughts on this but first let's just
look at vanderlein if she were to become
the next leader of NATO what is her
track record like well do you know this
expression fails sung no it means a sort
of some that always fails that's
actually quite straightforward
expression I probably should have known
it okay great let it a failed daughter
right she has endlessly failed in every
job she's done but she has been promoted
endlessly because she is the EU
equivalent the phrase I would know is
falling upwards she's falling output
there we go but she always gets promoted
because she is one of these sort of EU
figures that always gets the right job
and I think Joe Biden's interest in her
and Jill Biden's interested in her it's
connected to the fact that there is a
political class who are obsessed with
identity
and Ursula Wonderland Cuts This
brilliant figure in terms of identity
she's a mother of seven
she's a handsome woman who wears sort of
power suits and looks apart
but every job she's done she's done
disastrously that includes president of
European commission that includes
minister of defense for Germany a
spectacular failure she was in that role
uh the German troops were running out of
ammunition they'll be using broomsticks
instead of machine guns because they
were so badly equipped you haven't
exactly sold her Fred why do you think
Joe Biden would want behind the scenes
to whisper in ears about vondra line I
think they know each other
uh I think they've worked together over
China issues and so on when she was
president of European Commission
and I think I'm afraid it's as boring an
answer as identity politics do you not
think there's an element of Biden being
blatantly anti-british it wouldn't be
the first time that he's tried to snap
the UK with pro-european leanings I
think there's a little bit of that I
think we do as Brits have to be a little
bit careful when we make these
accusations because we're very chippy
particularly with Americans we the
relationship was delightful relationship
the relationship is unequal right so we
talk about the special relationship and
as Boris Johnson said when we talk about
the special relationship we sound needy
we sound like we we need American
Support
and so I don't necessarily think that
Biden is blocking it because he hates
Britain
although I do think he has a reflexive
anti-britishness
I think what he's probably doing is
doing identity politics and I think he
thinks a woman has to fill the role of
Secretary General of NATO and therefore
it's got to be a woman
if Ben Wallace was a woman
he might get the role might get the role
Biden is going to be traveling back to
the UK shortly what do you think we can
expect from that trip I think the sunac
administration number 10 are very keen
that this should be a big reset of the
special relationship of the relationship
between the US and the UK
but it's fair to say under Biden for
various reasons it's not gone well it's
partly that Biden doesn't like Britain
he sees himself as an Irishman who has
to hate Britain it's partly that the
Democrats hate brexit and so they see
themselves as hostile towards a brexit
government
but then set against that Rishi sunak is
saying I am the tip of the spear for
NATO I am the person who's going to lead
the war effort for you
and so in theory they have much more in
common in terms of geopolitics than they
have separating them but I don't think
he's been very receptive to Britain and
I think that's a problem for for us
certainly and possibly for America
Freddie thanks for joining me and
finally trigger warnings are supposedly
used to make people aware of harmful
content but have they spiraled out of
control Tom Slater has written about the
latest decision by publishing houses to
put trigger warnings on some of our most
cherished literature he's with me now
Tom thanks for joining me you have
written for coffee house about what's
happening to Virginia Woolf books in the
United States they're getting some
trigger warnings yes this is a very
strange one so vintage us the publishing
house has issued these new editions of
to the lighthouse Virginia walks 1927
novel in which it essentially warns
readers that it was written in 1927 and
then therefore it might not perfectly
reflect all of the attitudes and Views
that we hold in 2023 it goes as far as
to say the reason that we published it
unadulterated and unchanged is not to
endorse those particular views
um it's a curious one not least because
to the lighthouse there's not a
particularly outrageous or in
particularly political novel you know
it's a quite psychological exploration
of a world to do family holiday on the
Isle of Skye what vintage us thought was
so potentially perilous about it I'm not
entirely sure but it does seem to be
this is something that they're doing to
almost any book of a certain age so
concerned are they that the reading
public are so much less intelligent than
them I guess they don't seem to think
that they can understand that books
exist within a certain historical
context and that by publishing they're
not endorsing them but unfortunately
that's quite kind of philistine world
that we live in now it seems like well
I'm going to admit to my vested interest
here Mrs Dalloway is one of my favorite
books of all time so I'm concerned about
what book they may come for next uh but
you know it's funny how quickly things
shift I mean perhaps not that quickly
I'm dating myself here but when I was in
university 10 years ago I was taught
Virginia Woolf as this feminist icon you
know as this rather Progressive figure
for her time and then we jump forward 10
years and Trigger warnings are being put
on her books now as you say at that time
a lot of people held what we would now
consider to be backwards views but the
fact that that is front and center of
her work rather than the more
Progressive things she was saying at the
time in certain areas like feminism is
what's being upheld
now I think that is really interesting
how quickly people can be kind of
dispensed with I mean it's vintage us or
anyone else is worried about the views
of certain modernist authors you know
heaven forbid they find out who Ezra
pound is there's all kinds of people of
all kinds of very curious and unpleasant
views from that particular period in
time it's odd as you say because someone
like wolf went from being almost a kind
of feminist heroine in the eyes many
people in literary establishment I mean
I think it's worth saying that this
particular warning and the kind of
warnings that we're seeing proliferate
now is not just at vintage us Nancy
miffford's novels have been slapped with
trigger warnings in the UK recently
um is effectively about submitting
almost any text or any author to the
crudest of political Purity tests you
know even if there's just a character in
a particular novel that might be seen as
a little bit nasty rather than trusting
a reader to understand that that's
fictional one thing but also that might
not that one doesn't go to a novel just
to see a perfect reflection of their own
view of the world that seems to have
gone out of the window so I think what
we're looking at here is something
that's even Beyond just the standing of
particular authors it's just a much
broader
patronizing culture which assumes that
we need this kind of like therapeutic
scaffolding just to read books and
that's a really depressing thing as much
as anything else that's an interesting
point about trust I've been reflecting
on that point as well it it doesn't
always seem like it's so much about the
content of the book but rather how the
reader will interpret that content and
very often it seems like the assumption
is that there is no way that they could
critically assess what they're taking in
um and so if a character is perhaps
supposed to be good and has backward
views or is supposed to be bad and that
is indicated by having backward views
it's almost as if the context doesn't
matter or the individual can't work this
out for themselves it has to be made
very very clear to them from the outset
what they're about to consume and I
think that's exactly right and it's so
deeply genuinely offensive I think to
the intelligence of the reading public I
think going back to that Nancy mitford
example so her about the Pursuits of
Love is published in 1945 penguin bring
out this new edition and they say that
contains prejudices that will
commonplace in British Society at the
time they even went the extra step to
say that those prejudices were wrong
then and wrong now
um I haven't read the book myself on
very reliably informed that that seems
to reference one particular character
he's almost like a comical xenophobe
he's not someone you're expected to root
for in this particular novel but yet
even so there's this Terror that someone
somewhere might pick it up and think
that they should just unthinkingly
imbibe these particular views even when
they're expressed by someone
cartoonishly unpleasant so I think that
lack of trust in the audience is
definitely there I think the other thing
that we need to be very
cognizant obvious the fact that this
culture of kind of almost comical
offense taking that we're seeing this
desire to preempt what's seen as the
Thin skinned concerns of some imaginary
reader no we used to see this a lot on
University campuses we still do to a
large extent there was often I think a
complacency that that kind of cultural
trigger warnings which is great
um on University campuses was certainly
when they first took Route that all of
that was basically just student trip
reason that it wasn't going to escape
into the outside world I think it's very
clear now that we all kind of live on a
University campus now that those
students who 10 years ago were making
headlines by calling for trigger
warnings and all kinds of books they've
gone out into the world of work out into
our institutions out into our publishing
houses and they haven't less those
prejudices of their own behind they want
those places to be a safe space as well
they brought all the bubble wrap and the
cotton Wool with them so I think what we
need to recognize is if you know while
we're often invited to kind of laugh at
some of the world excesses of University
campuses if we don't want that to spill
out into General Society we really need
to start taking these arguments on
because they're just going to fester and
permeate more of our institutions well
let's have some of those arguments I'll
play devil's advocate here you note that
these trigger warnings have not yet
spread to the UK Edition when we get
deeply upset and flustered about what's
happening in the U.S if it's not
happening in the UK or certainly not
same extent do we risk importing that
kind of American culture war that
actually we would just like to avoid
altogether and don't particularly want
to have that debate in the UK well I
think we're importing it already is the
points so when this first kind of kicked
off about 10 years ago in the U.S you
saw loads of demand for children
warnings again it seems a very American
thing now that is everywhere in British
University campuses there was a story
earlier this year which is about Peter
Pan been given a trigger warning
Aberdeen University so you know if we're
worried about importing it that ship has
already sailed and I also think even in
terms of the publishing world that
whilst this this particular example was
referring to Vintage us uh there are
various examples which have already
taken place of publishing houses take it
upon themselves it's going to stand in
Judgment of previous authors in some
respects it's gone even to a greater
extent here if you think about what
happened with Roald Dahl and the attempt
to rewrite his books because they were
deemed too unpleasant and too spiky for
children to read if anything that's far
worse than slapping a trigger warning on
it and that's something that we've been
seeing within our own kind of domestic
publishing Market it is regrettable that
we are sort of Downstream for American
authenticate on many of these particular
questions but at the same time we can't
ignore the fact that that is what's
taking place
would you agree that trigger warnings
are appropriate on certain kinds of
content wolf and her books are a
fantastic example of how sensitive some
people are being but what about on
social media you get some explicitly
violent content going around and indeed
sometimes that's the point I'm thinking
of something like police violence or
brutality against civilians that is
deliberately designed to be spread and
and shared with the masses so that
people can react to it do you think
there should be a warning if you're
about to see a real person get stabbed
or get shot before you press play well I
think when we're talking about things
like social media that becomes a
slightly different example because it's
something that could quite easily be
thrust upon you by the seed you know and
I I think there's kind of questions that
social media companies could look into
around making sure that people aren't
bombarded or exposed to things that they
might not otherwise want to see I think
a lot of that can come down to filters
and so on I think the thing about
trigger warnings themselves in terms of
usually slapped on books and films and
so on is that they were often there was
a kind of acceptable case for it at one
point which is this idea that some
people have PTSD some people have very
traumatic experiences and therefore
reading a book that might have a scene
in it which might remind them the worst
thing that ever happened to them could
be terrible for them and therefore you
want to preempt that the thing is
there's been a lot of research on this
ever since they first came into public
Consciousness and it's pretty clear now
that even if your concern is making sure
that people who have suffered sort of
genuine traumas aren't triggered in the
literal sense then trigworn is actually
a terrible idea this is not how you
treat people who have traumas and PTSD
the whole point of therapy is to make
them comfortable in the world again so I
think when it comes to that question of
trigger warnings in particular there's
never really been a good case for it and
I think the problem with them is that
it's also not just about people who are
genuinely suffering it's about treating
us all as effectively as kind of
mentally unwell in need of that kind of
support and it's that culture the feeds
of thinking everyone's going thinking
everyone's a victim that I find so
objectionable and if they can't help but
breed calls for censorship
is there not simply a case for more
choice for example vintage U.S can put
this trigger warning on a book and if
I'm opposed to trigger warnings I can
jump on Amazon and buy an old version of
the book you know it doesn't necessarily
have to be so black and white does it
perhaps some people want that kind of
warning other people don't and surely
that's all right
I think choice is an important point I
mean when we're talking about this
particular trigger warning I mean it's
not the as outrageous as something like
we've seen recently with the attempts to
actually rewrite authors and I think
what was quite outrageous about some of
those is where Choice was actually
removed it wasn't immediately obvious
when they were rewriting rolled over it
so you were going to be able to buy
those original versions that's now um
the case but it wasn't clear from the
outset so I'm all for choice I think my
issue with trigger warnings in
particular I'm not trying to suggest
that this is like the starsy or
something it's purely because of the
fact that it reflects a philistinism
paternalism
culture of victimhood which I think is
is unpleasant and even though this might
not be the most excessive example of
kind of meddling with pastors and sound
that we've seen recently it's another
reminder that that culture is very
firmly held amongst our Elite nissari
institutions Tom you've written quite a
bit about how true warnings are
affecting literature Dare I ask who are
you worried could be the next victim
what's funny about trigger warnings is
that they seem to attach themselves to
almost anything I mean we've already
mentioned Peter Pan I mean what possibly
at a university you can be upset my
piece of advice not entirely obvious
there was another one I think it was in
Scotland as well where Beowulf got
slapped with a trigger warning because
it contained monsters and if you wanted
another example of how
infantilizing this is surely that is a
is a perfect example but there's no
rival reason to it I think what we've
got is a kind of free floating culture
of offense
um and surely a much better way out of
this is just to treat University
students members of the public people
who read books as adults and trust them
to get on with it but that seems to be a
pretty heretical idea and a lot of
literary circles
Tom thanks for joining us spectator TV
that's it for this week once again
thanks to Canada coach annuity wealth
management for sponsoring the week in 60
minutes can a crow will provide you with
the expertise you need to help build
your wealth with confidence because it
can do wealth.com for more information
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]